congratulations on your victory today it
was very impressive how do you feel
about it do you feel happy after winning
one more game
well i'm surely i can't say that i'm
excited about this game here but uh i
couldn't understand what what was he
doing but clearly
he's not showing uh
anything close to his no no to his
normal chess
uh well uh i guess okay this whole play
like g4h4 is ever optimistic but uh
i feel like more or less he plays every
game for for a win but i'd say yeah here
uh
i mean there there was like no basement
at all for why to play like this because
it came like how's all these pieces
developed so it's just
refused it's easy
yeah after he played this g4 move and
instead of instead of h4 did you
consider him to play a four and after
what what did you plan to play i
couldn't uh i couldn't guess his move
starting with f3 so
i mean okay each one is more or less uh
natural but then okay
uh he fought for so long so i thought
like maybe instead of a4 he will go for
some g4h for start but okay it's clearly
it never works because i mean it's like
uh because this is you know these are
the laws of the game here i mean you
can't really you can't really go like
and push like this uh without any
development but
yeah i guess
at least it was creative
that's for sure and i wanted to ask you
like what do you think
you are doing special during this
tournament that things are going so good
so far is it something about your
routine or anything else i don't know
i'm just playing the chess
preparing
some restless
as much as i can yeah and then i keep
again preparing again playing so it's
more or less normal routine but
i don't even know what to mention
have you had chance to check the game of
fabiano today and what do you think
about it i i mean very briefly but i
think he's pressing but
it's far from being obvious
do you think that uh second place is
also important in this event the
candidates tournament have you thought
about it
that's a question to
some other players because okay i'm
not really into all these you know
toxins
people who speak less about it yeah
thank you very much jan and all the best
in the next round